dans les rues d'abidjan il ne peut
rouler inaperçu pour tous les jeunes
ivoiriens qu'ils étaient partisans de
ouattara ou de gbagbo il est le grand
frère c'est la star du reggae africain
alpha blondy je crois beaucoup de bons
jours ok que ce soit du camp des pseudos
vainqueur ou du camp au checkpoint à la
sortie d'abidjan pas besoin de sortir
ses papiers
moi c'est ça ma blonde dit de le léguer
[Musique]
tout le monde me dit la même chose
grand frère vraiment illinois il faut il
faut contribuer à la réconciliation
[Musique]
un mythe vivant alpha blondy ses 35 ans
de carrière internationale quinze albums
et des succès mondiaux son repaire à
abidjan c'est son hôtel restaurant c'est
là qu'il fait découvrir à ses amis ses
nouvelles chansons qui tire le bilan de
la crise ivoirienne
la bataille d'abidjan
[Musique]
j'adore voir
evariste c'est son arrangeur c'est le
premier à écouter ce mixage réalisée à
paris en moins d'un débutant son reggae
a toujours été une arme redoutable pour
dénoncer les travers de ses
contemporains
là ils condamnent ceux qui ont utilisé
le concept ethnique d'ivoirité pour
asseoir leur domination politique
[Musique]
l abrasion ibérique
ce soit le pouvoir on espère qu'ils vont
plus envoyé l'offrande à l'abattoir
alors que pour une fois il va nous
écouter
on n'est pas des politiciens mais nous
sommes le vrai thermomètre comme la
musique adoucit les moeurs nous voulons
faire une thérapie collective
ok espère à genève message de paix et de
réconciliation pour en soigner les
blessures de tout un chacun
[Musique]
à la demande du nouveau président
ouattara alpha blondy a réuni autour de
lui une vingtaine d'artistes qui devrait
se produire dans le pays pour une série
de concerts le reggaeman connaît
l'impact de ses chansons mais les hommes
politiques aussi tous les présidents
depuis 25 ans ont cherché à le récupérer
et son statut d'idole le rend parfois un
poil mégalo
ce que j'aime chez aujourd'hui hélas
comme jésus-christ
quand on a besoin de comprendre alors et
quelqu'un c'est lui qu'on sort quand
même le crucifié quelqu'un c'est lui
qu'on va chercher
tu vois donc deux fois 7 fesses c'est
pénible
les politiques toujours quand vous quand
vous avez le pouvoir de regrouper mille
deux mille dix mille 5000 personnes l'om
d'une personne ils viennent ils viennent
systématiquement vers vous croyons
favoriser la paix il a soutenu laurent
gbagbo qui s'est même rendu un de ses
concerts ici à bassam en 2007
[Applaudissements]
qui a annoncé un an avant les élections
beaucoup mon candidat
c'était avant l'impact c'est de la
partie quelque part une robe est même
bon match je reconnais que je suis
politiquement naïve je suis naïve
politique
je reconnais sur la possession
politiciens je suis un artiste après les
élections alpha blondy appelle gbagbo à
se retirer et à reconnaître le verdict
des urnes
une prise de position qui lui vaut des
menaces et l'obligent à rester à
l'étranger
aujourd'hui il a retrouvé sa maison
d'abidjan une demeure à la démesure du
personnage d oie signalent les intrus
une déco locales traditionnelles
côtoient sur les murs les nombreux
trophées du musicien
alors là on a essayé de donner une
dimension africaine la cour in étoiles
de korhogo les quitte à tout ça se voit
ça se fait par le parisien par les
artisans ok ivoiriens fier de son pays
l'artiste se méfie des mauvais génies
politiques qui l'ont plongé dans la
crise et à trois grands partis
politiques en côte d'ivoire hague en
gros ma dès l'es3 grogne le court grand
groupe ethnique de côte d'ivoire et les
trois grands partis représentent ça
c'est dangereux on n'a pas le gars il va
pas dans un parti à cause du programme
politique
il va parce que le patron du parti
appartient à son groupe ethnique one et
n'y voit sa région c'est ça le danger
la mentalité tribale et ethnique sont
sont trop présentes dans en ou pour que
le multipartisme ne dérape pas sur le
plan tribales
malgré ce constat le chanteur croit dans
les chances de son pays
ils y investissent est revenu dans du
solide après des mois d'arrêt il
relançait chantier le plus important le
voilà au grand jour c'est un centre
commercial en construction en passer par
là on passe par là les travaux ont
démarré il ya déjà quatre ans on a merci
mon garçon pour moi après d'accord ça va
ça va gérer ce projet là il espère
inaugurer d'ici un an ou deux
ces galeries lafayette ne pas galérer la
faillite et qu'elle avait la paillette
pour lui ces parfums constitue une forme
d' épargne trois jours les revenus de
chaque tournée de concerts à l'étranger
sont investis dans ces matériaux
ça va ok ça avance bien d'accord normal
si tout va bien il ya 50 magasins une
boîte de nuit et plus loin
un restaurant sur le toit ok 1 vision
panoramique
je ne peux pas vivre ailleurs je vis ici
en côte d'ivoire et cet investissement
participe à droite et pessimiste
tu comprenant je peux croire en dieu et
j'ai foi en la côte d'ivoire on ne peut
investir que dans la paix hockey et j'ai
toujours défendu la stabilité politique
entraînera la stabilité économique et
c'est valable et pour la presle d'ivoire
pour tous les pays africains pour faire
avancer la cause de la réconciliation
alpha blondy a montré l'exemple
derrière ses murs un studio mythique où
enregistrer tous les grands artistes
africains
alpha blondy retrouve ici tiken jah
fakoly l'autre star du reggae ivoirien
les deux artistes s'étaient brouillés
pour des raisons politiques
aujourd'hui sonne l'heure de la
réconciliation tiken jah fakoly voilà
auquel le descendant sa fille fakoly
voir si le shaq violon et c'est chez lui
que on a fait le premier album alpha
blondy capturés dont je lui dois une
fière chandelle
quand alpha blondy soutenait gbagbo
tiken jah fakoly a toujours évité de
prendre parti ou de se faire récupérer
par un camp ou l'autre leur
réconciliation qu'il scelle ce jour-là
en musique et symboliques ont dix ans
que tu vois la paix n'est pas un vain
mot c'est un comportement
nous disons aussi que la réconciliation
ce n'est pas un faible s'est fortement
et c'est ce comportement qu'on appelle
tous les ivoiriens tant que ya pas la
stabilité la tranquillité
il est difficile de retrouver un pays en
voie de la côte d'ivoire avant d'être
derby le pl pays mais nous sommes une
nation est notre force dans cette nation
c'est notre diversité ethnique fait leur
force
mais quand les politiques ok on utiliser
cette cette arme technique ok sauf foutu
le bordel fabrique aussi des décisions
tout sauf des méchas
[Musique]
ok demain
en deux
quoique
tout est plus grand
à
[Musique]
moi pas pour nous les ivoiriens de nous
donner la main pour que conçu notre pays
que chaque chose a son temps gagné
l'union chanter en anglais en français
mais surtout dans toutes les différentes
langues du pays
[Musique]
banks
une chanson qui sera peut-être le
prochain tube en côte d'ivoire
quand il veut fuir les pressions le
chanteur part avec sa famille à bassam
c'est son jardin secret un havre de paix
au bord de l'océan
c'est là qu'il a commencé à bâtir un
hôtel de 50 chambres et financer
l'installation de l'électricité pour
tout un village
moi c'est sûr à faire
avec les stars
il avait investi dans l'espoir d'une
paix les travaux ont été stoppés
longtemps à cause des événements ils
reprennent doucement avec un
entrepreneur du coin
mais le voir
et la chambre d'un euro sont tout de
suite ok
selon lui pour que la paix soit durable
il reste encore à extirper les racines
du mal et faire le procès du
nationalisme à l'origine de la crise par
contre c'est pas détruit qui est
difficile ce qui est difficile c'est
bâtir tu comprends ok j'ai toujours
défendu j'ai toujours dénoncé l'
ivoirité est aujourd'hui j'aurais pu me
dire c'est bon là monsieur ouattara est
un président c'est beau maintenant c'est
pas fini et là je rejoins ceux qui
disent que c'est pas fini
un moment donné il faut qu on arrête le
camion hockey etc on désinfecte de ce
concept des structures et déstabilisant
pour la côte d'ivoire
[Musique]
son discours politique chanté depuis des
années a donc évolué au gré des
changements qui ont divisé la côte
d'ivoire mais aussi d'une certaine
maturité
à 58 ans l'artiste espère que ces textes
contribueront à réunifier son pays
[Musique]